there are some top grade talent in town  who's ready to make history but this is  the next level go on take it and learn  Magnus walkers in time and we smashed  that legendary running 50 I'll have to  come back to us check this so you guys  talk some fast runs out there was really  impressive we know about ken Block right  move in today so we go  Travis mentioned you worked a couple  prize yourself that's cool use whatever  tool you want I want it ready for not  post honesty before he leaves the city  I'm talking stupid power  gun crew you running would be  risky soon your moves killing it  everybody someone fighting against  system do you gotta ask yourself are you  the kind of drive reason for the rush  you